John had a shot to fame with the 2004
Indian Napoleon Dynamite now just a few
years later he pretty much disappeared
from the spotlight and these days it
seems like movie studios want nothing to
do with him so why isn't John had a
welcome in Tinseltown anymore what are
you gonna do alright feel like I wanted
God one-hit wonder this isn't to say
that Jon Heder is a bad actor he's made
some enjoyable films it's just that no
matter what he does he's never going to
shake Napoleon Dynamite in school for
scoundrels he attempted to play a
romantic lead in blades of glory he
played an eccentric disgraced figure
skater yet whenever audiences hear or
see his name they expect to see the
curly head bespectacled nerd who danced
his way into movie watchers hearts a
string of flops again Heather had made
some good flicks Just Like Heaven and
Monster House both found financial
success critical praise or some
combination of the two but if you look
at his filmography those are the
exceptions to the rule most of his films
like mama's boy or bling were greeted
with critical wrath or outright and
difference even worse most of his later
films have made very little money
whether or not that is headers fault his
name is attached to those projects not
that nerdy take away the hair the
glasses and the vote for Pedro t-shirt
and header looks nothing like the
awkward but heroic nerd fans talking for
in Napoleon Dynamite in real life head
of resembles a classic rugged leading
man with a 5 o'clock shadow square chin
and sharp jawline perhaps when the geek
masses saw the true header they felt
betrayed and turned their backs on him
voiceover work even though we haven't
seen that much of Jon Heder lately it
doesn't mean he's out of the picture in
fact he's been behind it
beginning with 2005's Monster House
Hedda has booked a lot of voice work for
video games animated films and car
earns what the flip phone are you doing
I was just hopping out little pickle
here's trouble breaking down the kernels
with this tiny little baby
he's also lent his voice to an animated
series based on Napoleon Dynamite to
date he's had almost 20 voice credits
and the work seems to be ramping up it's
not surprising considering his
distinctive voice hi Randy delivering
the papers again yes yeah that's the
same question every day so it could be a
matter of him not wanting to bother with
Hollywood anymore which brings us to his
other venture on the web whilst this
prolific voiceover career keeps him busy
hada hasn't completely retreated from
the camera like many creative
professionals he's gone to work for
himself by taking his talents to the
Internet since 2009 had has appeared in
web exclusive programs like the zombie
comedy woke up dead with these
successful online ventures and the
creative freedom that they offer there's
no reason for him to bother with
Hollywood productions
he already has all the opportunity he
needs uncontroversial John had a leads a
fairly innocent life and the reason
movie watches are attracted to some
celebs is that they're human train
wrecks or film fans clamor for a star
who's overcome a serious debilitating
problem either way Hollywood loves a
good controversy after all there's no
such thing as bad publicity had has
never had any problems like that nothing
sensational ever really occurred in his
public life in fact he's even made sure
to stay away from potential projects
because they've conflicted with his
mormon faith and he believed that
attract the wrong kind of attention he
might be so squeaky clean that there's
nothing for gawking ticket buyers to
stick to what's next John header could
revive his career pretty easily and he
doesn't have to compromise his values to
do it and seeing how he's worked on
multiple platforms it's pretty much up
to him how he gets his productions to
the people
murmee rules bird with pub is true and
centaurs poor Luke and Easley
all if nothing like that pants out you
can always take off the cap and train to
become a cage fighter
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which John header
roles have been your favorite